[Music]
back to work beer cart girl this is
exactly what Augusta was afraid of
that's Tania and when she's not
qualifying for tournaments
she's turning trick shots for the gram
she's the second best follow on the tour
right after Dustin Johnson's wife she's
like the Harlem Globetrotters of golf
except they don't allow people from
Harlem into country clubs her greatest
trick is making the most boring sport in
the world watchable she looks good in
short shorts and doesn't follow the
rules like Pauly Shore in 1993 she's in
the LPGA which is like men's golf but
with scissoring the biggest difference
is that the golfers stop every five
bends to ask the other ladies if they're
mad at them oh I have Tonya on my Mount
Rushmore of female athletes alongside
Serena Williams The Fabulous Moolah and
Kathy Ireland as the kicker in that one
movie and God willing
someday Tonya will be old fat and
starred in commercials to let us know
that Buick still makes cars just like
her male counterparts for Daniel Tosh's
2019 celebrity pro-am simulated golf
trickshot tournament charity
[Applause]
welcome to my celebrity pro-am simulated
golf trickshot tournament charity I'd
like to thank my sponsors for this event
potatoes they're back today that it way
today
today oh yeah what is it Pacific
Islander what are you we're just
guessing well yeah kind of - looking at
you so my mom is cook Island Hawaiian
Tahitian uh-huh
my dad's wife Oh congratulations
is that what you trick shots because
Arizona so boring no how often
are youth working on trick shots versus
just your game in golf in season I'll do
like ninety percent go I'll turn four
cent trick shots I basically just made
the content so you're only doing it for
the gram favorite trick shot that you've
completed probably the flip cap one so
it took me on enough like six hours I'll
never be able to repeat that again have
you ever trying to do another one again
the exact same one no pretty much every
trick I've done I'm like that's am done
it's like candy crush when she first
stage yeah no one ever replays a level
interlocking or overlapping I can now I
enter luck
why because I went through a window when
I was younger and I cut my arm yeah
that's a great score and so I went to
surgery they were like we have to cut
your arm up from your shoulder so much
less ma'am I think everybody has a story
like oh I almost lost mom but did you
really almost look how close like going
into surgery to cut it off and then also
and then they just try to repair it
what's your best 18-hole score in
tournament 9-under
I had 10 birdies 10 birdies I had a
bogey
because I tried to hit this par 5 in two
and my ball plugged in the bunker so
you're not consistent yeah
[Music]
are you sponsors yeah do you want more
sponsors oh yeah
I always trying to throw a Subaru a bone
I always just put it in on my show
without asking then when I was like hey
kind of Subaru they're like yeah what's
your favorite golf movie epic Elmo
really well I did trick shots
oh it broke it there we go
that's good about that so I can affect
my game did Phil Mickelson get a good
job that's what I always wanted to know
I've heard a lot of stories about this
stuff mostly because I was a witness to
win a Steve Williams stories uh-huh big
X Tiger caddy and I guess they're not
friends so he was talking about some
fans hit clean him about about his
breasts about sometimes you can see him
jiggle whoa my favorite golfer Mikki
d'amour at oh my goodness he tied 56 at
the US Open I was pretty good man he was
in the US Open he beat Tiger Woods he
gets to say that for the rest of his
life
Subaru needs a sponsor my nephew
immediately shouldn't ladies teams be
the same distance because men and women
are equal now take that clear that not a
coal because they're getting paid way
different but you're only getting paid
based off of your draw I mean I'm not
opposed to long across this cuz distance
is an issue friend Oh who's the greatest
female golfer Walton I'm gonna guess
this Annika Sorenstam I think the best
female golfer of all time is Elin
Nordegren probably per swing has made
the most money and guy is do better
trick shots than you a couple but for
the most part trick shots are genderless
yes well it's good that's amazing I
could they have a few trick shots that
the guys couldn't do but let's save that
for some weird bar and Tia wall
let's meet my plane partner part pro
park celebrity all Kiwi New Zealand's
Tania terror and a Bordeaux threesome
would be complete without the shapely
legs a virtual celebrity Tina Turner
[Applause]
what give me that - asshole quick little
factory reset language of choice Hebrew
now I'm not gonna play nobody gets any
charity it's a virtual course Chad a big
dumb beefcake
[Applause]
ready yes
get in the hole Dolph is an elitist
hobby
[Applause]
hi pork stuff there's life good Jack
give this bunny
oh dear home
[Music]
Oh got a virtual Spreaker Tina Turner
talks with draw on your wins you're
gonna want to screen grab this check
print it out then find the dumbest bank
teller in the world golfer has ever been
allowed on television you are welcome
you